i mean listen i love crocodiles i don't
want to you know put any fear into
people regarding
crocodiles but when it comes to a big
crocodile yeah i mean that's one of the
few animals
in the wild that could totally look at a
person and if they're of the right size
meaning like you know 11 12
plus feet probably you know maybe bigger
depending on how big a person is
dude you could be food and they they
will consume you and eat you and make a
meal out of you
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
on the show today is someone that we
know as the sexy vet however his name is
dr
evan anton he has a book that came out
called
world wild vet he has a huge facebook
show called tusk to tale
look if you want to know anything about
animals especially exotic animals this
guy
loves crocodiles or crocodilians i think
he called them
which i did not know what that was but
apparently it's a conglomerate of all
um crocodile species and and alligator
species
you also are gonna learn about his hobby
which
i've already asked for an item from this
hobby that he's taken up
i think this is going to be something
that he's going to probably make a
side or second or an extension of a
career out of
because he's very talented at it and i
also learned that i'm
now going to give driving lessons so we
have a lot of similar interests so
i hope you enjoy the show yeah i love
animals but i especially love dogs oh
that's super cool yeah i love dogs we
got we got our dog
show me me today he's a little wolf you
could say
hmm oh no not but you could
i mean you know the littler the bigger
the bark
he thinks he's a wolf at times i mean i
can say that at least
yeah um well you got to be careful a
little bit in la for
animals right oh absolutely yeah i know
we i hear coyotes around here every once
in a while i've never seen anything
like in my in my yard or property but
yeah anytime i let them out it dusk dawn
or night time i'm a little
i'm i'm babysitting them outside like
i'm out there with them
oh we have skunks more than ever
anything though i mean these skunks here
are so trigger happy
i feel like it's been once a week lately
at least that they're i'm just like
smelling skunk in my house it's crazy
they're so busy
around here and they're close yeah it's
kind of intense i mean it's cool to see
them like i love seeing skunks running
around the yard and
just being a part of the you know the
nature and the they are one of the
native species here but
man sometimes they make the house smell
pretty funky
i do i i mean i get that i mean look i'm
not gonna probably see a skunk running
around and think quite as excited as you
but i would love to see like in arizona
here we get like
javelinas oh yeah yeah yeah coyotes
um you know those kinds of things lots
of rabbits and my dogs just
go crazy for the rabbits the rabbits
yeah through obsession of theirs
um but then even like in other places
that i've lived too i remember i lived
in north carolina
and um it was on a really really big
property and there were deer on it
and for a hot second who i was living
with was
thinking that they'd let someone hunt
them and i was like if you ever want to
see deer on this property you can't kill
them
yeah and also please don't kill them i
feel right
oh um anyway there was like a deer stand
in the
in the in the in the back but i there
was no hunting going on but i love
seeing the animals from around it's like
we are totally in their space north
carolina has phenomenal wildlife i mean
they've got neat reptiles they've got
alligators they've got all kinds of cool
mammals and birds and birds of prey and
really need snakes and
actually i want to go to vet school
there for a minute because they've got a
good program but then i was so excited
by the wildlife and i know there's
you know good beaches and some surfing
there and it seemed like a pretty cool
spot to live actually
yeah it was really nice but you um do
you love
crocodiles right is that your favorite
animal yeah love
crocodilians yeah absolutely all right
would you call them
well so i said crocodilians yeah you do
what is that that basically encompasses
anything that's in that crocodile family
so it's alligators
crocodiles gharials and caimans
everything have you ever heard of a gary
you ever seen those really long snouted
narrow snout like a really long skinny
snout on a crocodile they're native to
it's called a gario they're native to
like india and nepal no dude
i don't see any of those things i've run
no way you ever see okay so this was a
good place they were represented kind of
because they're kind of
like a modern day dinosaur they've been
around for you know ten probably
hundreds of millions of years
and there was a character that resembled
pretty much a gharial in one of the ice
age movies
it was like what this like i also don't
watch any
um i don't watch anything that
is a cartoon or
anything like that no whatever i'm like
one of those that's like i'd be
punishing to have kids and have to watch
like cartoons i'd be like
i'm watching like you know spiritual
videos on
you know the shadow self and you know i
don't know the hero's journey in
quantum physics
so no i didn't but i love animals if
you're going to watch a cartoon maybe
you should watch rick and morty
rick and morty you ever heard of that
kinda
it's like the the creators are obviously
total science nerds and they're always
doing this funny time travel it's pretty
funny it's
it's a pretty renowned pretty it's an
adult cartoon okay so if you if you ever
feel like you want to explore cartoon
this is where i would encourage you to
start
other than that yeah maybe they're just
not for you so
um what is it about crocodilians then
that trips your trigger
i mean i think kind of like what i was
saying a second ago i mean they're
modern-day dinosaurs like some of our
crocodilian species have been around
unchanged evolutionarily for you know
hundreds of millions of years uh you
know some for probably over 200 million
years
and just to think you know hey this
animal's been around they haven't had to
change they've been they've been
successful
they've survived mass extinctions and i
mean to me they're just beautiful like
just aesthetically i think they're just
such
fascinating gnarly incredible looking
animals and their adaptations and their
ability to
ambush predate and everything their bite
force like they just
they're just so beautiful to me i just
find them so cool
so i went to tulum mexico for
a couple of weeks have you ever been
down there no i've not i mean uh
i've been nearby but i never got to
tulum and that's totally on my list yeah
um it's super great place it's really
good for
yoga and spirituality and a beach and
it's super quaint
quaint little town it's becoming a
little bit more popular
in general but also for a little bit
more partying which is not where i go
but however i stayed at this property
that um
was on the jungle side because it's
basically one little street and there's
beach side and there's jungle side
they stayed on the jungle side and they
have um
they have like a they sort of
pay homage to this resident sort of they
say crocodile
who is um protects the there's three
cenotes on the property
which are these sort of basically like
sinkholes and they're like sacred
sacred in that area and so in
so it's in charge of protecting this
cenote
um but then somebody else said they're
like don't jump in the big cenote
because that's where the crocodile lives
and then somebody's like now there's
there's not really a crocodile it's kind
of like
a hybrid of this and that and it's not
it's not it doesn't want humans it
doesn't bite
and so then but i'm going to go by the
fact that we shouldn't go in because
somebody said there's a crocodile
now do you know about that area and is
there some kind of
breed of crocodilian that doesn't want
to
feed on a human and what would make them
want to feed on a human
okay so to answer your questions yeah
number one there is the american
crocodile native to that part of mexico
and that is a species of crocodile that
gets really big i mean they can get up
to
i mean it's rare to find an 18-foot you
know uh
sized animal but that's totally possible
they often get 12 14
something feet they get huge any
crocodile species whether it's a
saltwater crocodile american crocodile
um a nile crocodile any of these big
monster crocodiles when they get to a
certain size
anything that is of size that could be
food
could be food they don't look at people
and be like like sharks for example
big sharks that could technically
totally chow down on a person
people do get bit by sharks rarely but
it does happen but
sharks pretty much never actually
consume people
because they're just a few bull sharks
that are you know they want to test bite
something they realize hey
this isn't gonna be right what's that
they get confused
yeah i mean i don't if they're not
confused well they're they're curious
and they're bold
okay and they they think i'm gonna try
this this might be good
it kind of resembles something i might
eat and then they take a bite they're
like i know
this doesn't taste good i don't want it
crocodiles no i mean listen i love
crocodiles i don't want to
you know put any fear into people
regarding crocodiles but when it comes
to a big crocodile
yeah i mean that's one of the few
animals in the wild that could totally
look at a person and if they're of the
right size meaning like you know 11 12
plus feet probably you know maybe bigger
depending on how big the person is
dude you could be food and they they
will consume you and eat you and make a
meal out of you so
in that area where there are huge
american crocodiles potentially
yeah i wouldn't swim in water where
there could be big wild um
potentially man-eating uh american
crocodiles
well all the cenotes are connected
underground
all of them oh so they kind of like go
between back yeah i mean you're
you're you might be playing with fire i
mean it sometimes when you go to certain
areas
if they're smaller water bodies only
smaller crocodiles or individuals live
there
okay and if you if you come across a
seven foot american crocodile
they're going to be way more scared of
you than you are of them they're not
going to try to attack they're not going
to yeah i mean it's
you're just not on the menu you're too
big you know they wouldn't think of it
i'm only five foot though
i look probably more delicious for
someone because i'm little
okay so i'm six too so maybe like a nine
or ten foot american crocodile might
look at you differently than they look
at me so
i whatever i say like in reference to me
just think of a little bit smaller
crocodile that might eat you and then of
course there's so many crocodile species
that don't look i mean they just don't
get a size where they'd ever consider
people
food so like the australian freshwater
crocodile i mean they max out at maybe
like seven or eight feet maybe a little
bit more but that's probably pushing it
um you have the more or less crocodile
which is not far from
uh tulum in that part of like um you
know southern north america
and central america and those guys maybe
get
i don't know maybe seven or eight feet
as well you have cayman species that
only get to three to five feet
you have other crocodiles even in like
the chinese alligator only gets to be
like six or seven feet or something like
that so
all these species would never look at
even you in a a
mighty five-foot would never even
consider you a meal so it just depends
on the species but if you're going to
africa
and you come across a big nile crocodile
at a watering hole
and you go and try to drink some water
from it or swim in it or whatever and
there's a 14 foot nile
your toast you know so it just depends
where are the most dangerous
um crocodiles or crocodilian
i think really depends more on the size
of
the individual honestly i mean like okay
alligator is the american alligator
what's the difference between a
crocodile and an alligator uh
geographic like where their name and
then of course i mean anatomically no i
mean
one tip that i've given it's a little
bit confusing but if you take the first
letter
of each of those words and then use that
shape
to resemble the snout of the opposite
then that's a way to kind of distinguish
so crocodiles have an
a shaped long snout okay
alligators have a c-shaped snow so you
kind of have to flip it
um and then the alligator's teeth when
you look at their mouth when it's shut
the t the upper jaw teeth of an
alligator when their mouth is shut are
the only ones you see you don't really
see many teeth from the lower jaw you
don't see any and on an alligator
there's like the fourth tooth back on
each side so when they close
they've got these big like lower teeth
that kind of stick up
that you can see kind of looks like my
dog then
yeah if you got a little underbite dog
some of those underbite dogs look like
little
little crocodiles for sure although it's
a belgian i have a belgian malinois
and uh oh i love those miniature
siberian husky
and so they they they they've got their
sort of longer snouts and fangs
those guys have things both like how i
just drew an analogy between my dogs and
a crocodile
i mean they're like the dog version of
crocodiles it's fair to say that
a malinois might be with their bite
malamas are pretty i mean i've worked
with a lot of malinois with my like
in the conservation world so a lot of
parks use them in africa they're they're
they're pretty good anti-poaching dogs
you know they've got really good drive
and they're very i mean they're that you
can train them to be just little killing
machines
and so they're pretty fast and they're
they're pretty incredible so that you
know
of course a lot of the police force in
the u.s works with them too i mean all
over the world
so more more often than not when i'm
working with malibu's these are not
you're cuddly on the couch dogs these
are
your working dogs and you don't want to
be on the wrong side of that bite
oh ella's cuddly on the couch ella is
like yeah
the cuddliest on the couch she wants to
lay she's
if you're not touching her she's trying
to get you to touch her
she is she's a lover i feel like they're
very
um they have they're like master
oriented they have their person
and then their that's their person it's
100 true i mean
they want to please and they want to
work and they want i mean they want to
do whatever
it is that you want them to do in a lot
of ways you know they've been bred to
just
obey and and make their their you know
whoever is their trainer their owner
whoever to make them happy
you know so what's the smartest dog or
what's the smartest dogs
like i'm thinking if somebody's
listening and they want a dog i want to
go through like the smartest dogs like
the dumbest dogs
the most friendly dogs the meanest dogs
i mean okay so the smartest dogs i mean
man some of those aussie shepherds are
just
crazy smart i mean they're really like
like mature toddlers they're almost like
kindergartners you know i mean the
amount they can learn and how quickly
they learn and what they can do
they're capable of a lot i mean most
breeds are really smart and have the
potential to learn and do a lot of
amazing things
um i have the potential for math but i
can't do that so
you know right i mean as a human but at
the same time right
um i mean henry like my dog i just
showed you he's a little chihuahua mix
he's a rescue little guy and
you know he's um he's kind of simple
like he learns
i can teach him things he can know
what's good and bad and and you know he
picks up on my
you know what what i want to see or not
see pretty easily but at the same time
you know i wouldn't want to put him
through any kind of rigorous training
it's just not him
so i don't i wouldn't say he's dumb but
you know he's a simple guy and other
breeds you know some of those little
dogs can be a little bit simple you know
some of them
it's a nice way to put it yeah they can
be like a little like some of the
pomeranians i've met they're
they're a little bit on the simple side
yeah i mean but you know i've worked
with malteses and yorkies that are super
smart super smart dogs
okay well what's the uh what's the
nicest dogs then
i mean i think any breed has the
potential to be
just absolute sweethearts i mean
pitbulls are one of the most
underrated uh had they have such
remarkable misconceptions
they can be the most loyal sweet just
gentle dogs they wouldn't hurt a fly
i've seen so many of them be so gentle
with
little baby kittens and baby birds and
maybe humans in ways that are i mean
they know they need to be gentle they i
mean when you think about their
the ability they have in terms of their
strength their power their by force
just their overall weight and size and
they can just be so gentle to such
delicate little creatures so i think
really any breed has you know a lot of
potential for that and that's just one
breathing i think a lot of people
assume to be little killing machines
when really they're such good such good
loyal dogs
so then i suppose similarly on the other
side you'd say then that if i was going
to ask what the
what the meanest side is this meanest
animal it would be the same
like any dog can be mean like i have a
my dog dallas is
like the miniature siberian she's just
really protective of her space i say
that if she was
some dad's daughter it would be like the
dream daughter because she's very
protective of her space and she doesn't
let anyone touch her
right and i'd be like that would be like
every dad's dream daughter
totally i love that's hilarious you'll
spend a lot of time earning her trust
right exactly that's perfect that would
keep a lot of dads less stressed i'm
sure
um i mean some breeds are a little bit
more of a handful than us i mean so i'm
a veterinarian
i work i work with a lot of wildlife of
course but i also work in a veterinary
hospital and i work with a lot of
exotics and wildlife but
a ton of dogs and cats um there are some
dog breeds
and i know when i just see the breed
before i even meet the patient then
statistically there is a higher chance
this
this dog might be a bigger pain in the
butt than some of the other uh
breeds that i work with so some of those
um
sharpies can be a handful and i'm saying
what i'm saying i'm
pretty sure all my veterinary colleagues
would agree and all the vet techs and
people in the vet you know
industry out there would understand this
uh sharpays dalmatians can be a handful
chows can be a handful
um why mariners uh some some of the
german shepherds and and malinois and
dutch shepherds
you know especially like when i've
worked with police force ones they have
such
high drive and prey drive and they
they're they're trained and they always
want to work and so when they come in
the hospital they have to sit and run
for a few minutes
they start losing their mind so they can
be a bit of a handful too so those are
some breeds i might
anticipate potentially having a more
difficult patient but at the same time
i've had any one of those breeds be
total sweethearts and then i've had the
classic sweetheart breeds
i mean one i'd say one of the meanest
just one of the meanest dogs i've ever
worked with
was a golden retriever i mean that's the
american you know sweetheart right i
mean that's one of the
best sweetest dogs but i'm telling you
it happened what was the story
there was no apparent known i mean the
owners
were great owners they were super sweet
people i knew them and saw this patient
for many years they had kids i mean this
stuff there was no apparent reason as to
why this dog behaved the way it did
um and it they got it at a young age and
they gave it a great life
and it there was no unknown traumatic
experiences like i don't know
i i think it was just the way that dog
was wired i mean just like people
you know some people are just kind of
special and he was kind of special you
know
do you uh believe in reincarnation
i'm open to it you know i am i don't i
don't know but i
i you know who knows what happens to our
souls and where they go so i'm
i'm i'm open to it if that soul was an
[ __ ] and it needs to learn its lesson
yeah but why would you go
be a like a dog's life and like a really
nice
loving family in a in a in you know
a first world country like he should
have went and been like
you know some animal that like i don't
know there's a lot of sad stories for
animals but
i would have put a jerk somewhere else
so i don't know i mean you could be
right though maybe he was just kind of a
dick and it's like you need to be
humbled a little bit you need to be a
dog
and then he was just kind of grouchy
about it or his soul was
i 100 feel like i was a dog in another
life or i
perhaps there's a timeline existing
right now where i'm a dog because my
resonance for like their pain and
suffering and
love like when i go to other countries
like peru or
mexico or you know somewhere places in
the world where they're just
everywhere i mean i want to take them
all home
and do do you have that level do you
feel that for any animals in specific or
feel that at all or what like
what's the emotional level that called
you to animals
i mean it's a lot of what you're saying
i mean you just it's it's empathy
i mean that's what it comes down to
right it's just like putting yourself in
this animal shoes and
knowing every day's a struggle they
don't know if they're gonna eat they
probably have
a multitude of different tropical
diseases you know when we're talking
about these dogs we see in mexico or
peru or
you know southeast asia what i mean i've
seen i've seen it all too and it's
they're heartbreakers you know and um
you really you also see that these
a lot of these are just sweet animals
and they're misunderstood and they're in
places where people don't get their
needs met
and anytime you go to a country where
the people don't get their needs met
the animals aren't the first priority
and they're really not going to get
their needs met so that can be a really
sad story
and that's um i mean that that
in my experience and what i've seen that
that seems to be probably the biggest
correlative factor
as to why i see an excess of animals
that are just
you know street animals and this and
that there's miss you know lack of
education and then
people have their own struggles but do
you have like some kind of was there
some sort of moment
of some story something that happened
that was really like
emotional for you that catapulted you
into the work that you do especially
doing
because you travel a lot like getting
out of you know getting out into other
countries and
into the wildlife realm which is i mean
so far beyond just being a veterinarian
and
you know locally
um honestly i've always known animals to
be a big part of my life whether it was
just personally or if it was personally
and professionally i didn't honestly
know i wanted to be a vet until i was in
early in college
and i was taking some intro to bio
courses and i took an evolutionary
biology course and i
that was the first time in my life i
actually liked to learn i liked to study
i liked to
kind of delve into those subjects and
got really excited about it i had really
good teachers that were passionate about
it and that was a huge part of that too
um
you know i was always had appreciation
for medicine but there was a few things
that kind of played into that but that's
when i knew i wanted to be a vet but
i mean my i had pets growing up my
parents always said i was really gentle
with animals
i wasn't one of those kids and was too
rough with them or pulling on them or
pulling their ears or their tails like i
was always just really sweet with them
and
i've always had a big soft spot for
animals i mean it's i think again it
comes down to
like a it's an empathy you know i mean
they can't speak for themselves
and i'm i'm lucky that i i have a
natural ability to kind of read
animals i mean animals i say they don't
speak because they don't speak english
but animals do communicate and you can
learn a lot from their
from their facial expressions their
mannerisms their wags uh
you know everything they're doing i can
learn so much from an animal just within
a few seconds of
beginning to engage with one um and i
always you know i always loved that and
i you know i had pets all through my
life growing up my first dog was
actually a shepherd
doberman mix named bruno and um i mean
that was one of those dogs that was
super loyal
and was obsessed with me and i was
obsessed with him and we had this really
tight bond
and i've had that with animals my whole
life since then you know and
um i can't i can't like pin it on one
thing like this was like my aha
oh my god i'm like i love animals so
deeply it's just been
it's kind of been all along the way like
along my entire journey
they've been such a significant part of
my life on a personal and professional
level
what um what are the biggest differences
between
like animals and people because i know
there's similarities and i want to talk
about that too
but what are the differences like do
animals actually
need us uh yeah henry needs me
like for real he's he's extreme we have
a legitimate
codependent relationship so domesticate
animals
yeah i love that you know i said uh i've
said before i'm like look i know i
need to heal a little codependency in my
life but can i just shift that
codependency to ella
like if i could just be codependent with
ella a little bit i
feel like i could solve it for the rest
of people oh it's hilarious
um and then well so you were saying
what's
what's different so a couple things one
animals
never lie they're always honest and that
goes into people into being able to
communicate with them if i go into the
exam room
and i see an animal is uh you know
hiding behind their owner
and their their tails tucked between
their legs and their ears are back and
that you know they're they're telling me
they're they're communicating very
clearly i'm shy i'm nervous i don't know
you and i'm a little bit scared
whereas if i go into a room they're tail
wagging they're running to jump on me
they're
panting and smiling and just being
ridiculous like they're telling me hey
let's be best friends i can't wait to
play with you
so that's that's one thing another thing
is um and i love this about our pets you
know like
even just dogs for example but this goes
for a lot of animals but they live in
the moment
they're not regretting the past they're
not stressed about the future they're
not thinking about anything other than
right here right now and they're
enjoying that and making the most of
that and so when i come
home if i've been out all day and i see
my dog henry he's so happy to see me
right now he wants to enjoy
this moment right now and that goes for
every moment of their day
you know they just that's that's how
they live and i think you know
i think there's there's a i think it's a
beautiful thing you know i'm not you
know it's nice
to you know reflect on the place it's
nice to
you know have your future in mind but i
think it's also nice to live in the
moment
is it true that animals like um
that they have essentially short-term
memory loss in a way that they are it's
that they can't keep track of time
so one minute could be one hour could be
one day could be
like is that a true thing with that i
mean the way they behave would
would obviously indicate that when you
leave town for a week versus you leave
your house for 20 minutes your dog is
equally excited to see you
right on the occasion right so um i you
know i don't i don't i think they do
have more of a concept of time than what
they're giving credit for um but also
you can't
totally communicate to your animal hey
i'm just leaving for like 20 minutes
dude like
just chill everything's gonna be fine
i'll be back soon
um henry actually has learned he knows
and i'm leaving town and i try to like
mix up what i do but he he sees my
routines he sees me packing he sees the
suitcases he sees the backpacks
so he knows what's going on and every
time i start packing like
clothes on my bed like laying out what
i'm bringing or whatever he goes and
sits on them and pouts and looks
really sad and i'm like [ __ ] you know
what's going on like you know i'm going
to leave today or tomorrow or something
um watch is your dog uh i mean i have
pet sitters like i mean i've
yeah i've always worked that out does it
make you feel bad
because you feel like dr do you have
like rules for
the people watching your dog i mean i
have i mean like i cook my dog's food
for them and there's a lot of things
that they need to know about
my dog so someone's gonna watch them
yeah i mean i'm lucky my pet sitters
they ask all these questions if i don't
tell them they're asking me to tell them
like so they're they're uh they're
awesome
and they do everything i ask they do all
the little weird silly things it might
not even make sense and they're happy to
do it and they just i mean they send me
pictures of my pets every time they sit
and cuddle with them and
they uh they're awesome so yeah that all
works out luckily i mean i do feel bad
like
i mean other than you know last year i
was home a lot
you know a lot of borders were closed
and it was a unique year
but the last few years prior to that i
mean i'd be gone for like a third of the
year i was out of the country
you know so it's do you um do you ever
get sick of just talking about animals
no i don't think so don't i mean no i
love it honestly like i mean listen i've
had weeks where it's been
a long intense week at the vet hospital
and i just want to get home
and i just want to like get away you
know get it get out of there but like
i can talk animals all the time i mean
that's really that's all i'm good for
like if you want to start talking about
other stuff
you i'm not going to be very interesting
anymore so
well you so you only talk about if you
were to have a dinner
party like what would be the funnest
conversation
to have at the dinner table and you
can't say it you could say animals if
you want if you wanna
if you want to you can i mean i feel
like it depends on who i'm there with
like if i'm having
i've got my mom and little brother in
town and it's a little family dinner
you know we'll talk about pretty tame
stuff and it's fun and funny if i've got
some of my best friends over
you know you i probably shouldn't say
what would be the funnest thing to talk
about
you know come on
uh my friends are total perverts so you
know we you know no i'm just kidding um
yeah i know i don't like literally oh my
you should see the text dialogue i've
been having today on some of my group
chats
there you go messages i'm sure i know
what that's about yeah you get it
i mean you know it just depends on who
you're talking to i don't literally talk
animals constantly i mean usually when i
do podcasts or something like that
i'm probably going to be talking about
animals but i'm happy too i mean i love
it honestly i
like i think there's so much to to learn
from animals i think there's so much to
teach from animals i've
i've i've gotten a lot of really lucky
i've had experiences working with
animals over the world
and i've gotten to work you know up
close and personal with so many
different species and a lot of people's
you know some of their favorite animals
to work with like elephants or rhino or
crocodiles or venomous snakes or
gorillas or chimps or what have you
and um i love sharing those stories i
love educating people about that and
what's important regarding their
conservation and just unique interesting
things about them i mean there's
there's there's so much to be said
what are your other interests do you
have any other hobbies i mean like
obviously you keep very busy and you
travel for animals but
there must be other things you like
doing yeah absolutely so
this over this last year i got super
into woodworking
what my dad's a professional woodworker
can i see something
is there anything there that you made
you want to see my first real furniture
project
yes i'm so proud of and excited about
these so i i literally just started this
we're going to go for a little a little
walk here
so did you create like a do you have
like a woodworking shop and
and like yeah too if you want to see i'd
be happy to show you
please i'm going to try to see if i can
get you can you see that chair
yeah you made that i made these yeah
these are
amazing and they're like a they're
called a z
chair it's like a mid-century style if
you can see
i feel like you could sell that at um uh
what's that called
uh it's called design within reach i
like to call it design just out of reach
because it's actually very expensive
um but that looks like some sort of like
uh
old sort of 60s or mid-century yeah
they're totally mid-century it's called
a z chair it's a total
it's not your style i'm taking the
garage now sorry it's just dark here for
a second wow that's amazing
yeah thank you so just flipping on the
lights here here's the shop
and so this was my first big purchase
it's a big uh
table saw that's a huge table saw and i
made
i did design and make this it's a miter
stand
uh for my miter saw that's what that big
like chop saw is
workbench um those are a bunch of jigs
and jigs are things you use on your
tools
to do certain kinds of cuts and whatnot
and then my recent my most recent big
power tool purchase was this beast
yeah that's a band saw and it was uh
it was really nice to have making these
chairs but yeah no i'm totally nerd now
like i love this hobby it's been so much
fun
that's amazing you had a lot of time so
you made hot wood so quarantine
you benefited from quarantine with two z
chairs
you built your woodworking shop up and
what else did
did you make any did you make any like
holiday gifts for people
no i made i mean the first thing i ever
made outside the shop
was a was a a butcher like a cutting
board
oh yeah i need a cutting block can i can
i um
can i hire you out for a cutting board i
need a really nice cutting board
i made i signed some scrap maple and i
made this
beast of a cutting board i'll show you i
like it
really short so it can't be too thick
because then i'm up on my tiptoes
this one i mean it's over an inch but
it's not like crazy but it's
it's not little oh amazing
yeah i want a nice checkerboard one
because of my racing history
there you go okay i can do that i will
i'll
pay the top dollar with a walnut and
maple black and white
like a really light light white you know
lighter maple and some dark walnut
i love it look at look at see look where
we went now i have a cutting board and
everything
and maybe some z chairs at some point in
time those are incredible
oh thank you so much i'm really pumped
on him do you plan on
um see i love the idea that the things
that we just enjoy doing become
businesses so that's kind of how my life
has evolved
especially post racing just interests
like i love wine so i have two labels
now and
you know just various i love talking to
people and i have a podcast so
you know i take the things that i enjoy
doing and i just they somehow manifest
into
businesses so do you have you dreamt
into the sort of
like um into the full potentiality of
this
um passion project well so with i mean
when i okay when i made this cutting
board
i was thinking it would be really fun to
even if it's not like
uh becoming a part of my profession and
like my income
even just doing it like i was thinking
like doing a cutting boards for
conservation kind of thing
where i make you know personalized
cutting boards and then you know i
auction them off or something and raise
the money for
uh you know whether it's you know the
rhino uh rhino
anti-poaching organization i work with
or with you know for chimpanzee
conservation i've worked with or
elephants or what have you just
something you know something i can use
my that craft to then raise some money
and try to get
you know of that use that for something
um you just name the price for that
cutting board and i know that it's going
to go
to helping animals which is i'm you're
tugging out i mean that's why those
aspca commercials and all that like
sarah mclaughlin singing and you're like
i can't keep it together
um i mean because people want to help
they do
yeah no they do no it's funny so with
the racing i
didn't i should have thought of that so
that's something else and i've taken it
no i don't race i've not raced
um but i like i was never a huge car
person
and then a couple years ago i got really
excited about cars and like i love
muscle cars and i got a challenger and
did some modifications to it and it is
so damn fun and like i never had a stick
before i always had automatic cars i'm
like dude
yeah it looks so fun and now i can't
imagine
yeah having a stick like going automatic
and i'm yeah manual is so much fun
it's so damn fun it's like when you can
rev match and
every like oh my god it's just oh i
could teach you how to like
blip down shift i could teach you how to
i could teach you how to do all that
stuff i can teach you how to apex
corners
can
let's go okay so let's go snake hunting
in arizona we haven't gotten to that yet
but that's so
so good there like some of my favorite
rattlesnakes in the world are native to
not far from where you are
okay um let's get in the workshop okay
and then let's please go racing
i love that um i mean how long is this
project
is this hobby is that literally those
chair and that creation
just a year old like meaning as a hobby
or did you oh no
yeah no i literally so you saw did you
see the webbing on the chairs like that
rubbing so there's gonna go there's
gonna be cushions on the back and then
on the seat bottom so there's
i'm waiting for cushions that i'm having
made right now i literally
officially finished those chairs the day
before yesterday
i finished the webbing i mean this i've
i've been working on them for the last
couple of months and literally just
totally finished the finish i i used i
did a polyurethane finish
after doing a shellac and a stain and
you know everything no
that's like the most recent super recent
thing that just came out
i didn't get my i got my table saw in
april and so i
i everything just kind of started from
there so like i built and designed my
workbench
that might understand with all the
drawers that maybe you saw with it with
the chops
on it i built and designed that that
took a lot of time so everything else
has been shot furniture
and these are my real like these are my
projects of what i can do
outside the shop what i can actually
create with the shop so yeah it's all
very very new isn't it so fun how
you know we can take something
that we love doing maybe even just that
we're good at like if i'm gonna this is
a confession
um i've said it before so it's not like
it's brand new but
but it's it's just that you know racing
was what i did but honestly like
it wasn't a passion in a way that i
loved racing i loved
aspects of racing but it i don't go
watching it i don't go doing it i don't
do it for fun
like i do other things for fun and so
when i say that it wasn't
you know like i didn't love it it said i
didn't love racing itself and so it's
interesting how
sometimes and i don't i'm not saying
this is for you but obviously this is
something that you're really
good at obviously and and really
interested in and get very excited about
and how we can sometimes our life can
start one way
and just sort of turn left and or right
or
turn around and and and and take us to
these different places where
um we learn something else that we truly
love
but it's through the
original platform that gives us the
ability to do that other thing
in a really big way yeah no it's
fascinating it's so true and how we
evolve and
end up doing things i mean yeah i mean
like this woodworking it all started
because i wanted to build a new reptile
enclosure
for my pet snake and like my dad who he
does
he's a professional woodworker and
that's more of what he does on the side
his main income is through other means
and he's a stock market kind of guy but
he just loves working with wood he's
very passionate about it
and he's like son you got to get a table
saw and i barely knew what that was
and then i started investigating
exploring and i it just
it sucked me in at first and like it
applies
you know i mean it's working with your
hands which i do like and there is
some crossover and i do think being in
the veterinary field you do
have uh you know you do work towards and
have a skill set for that just you know
being a surgeon
and i do surgery and i you know i'm a
surgeon too just with uh with animals
obviously and
um i think that plays into it and then
just my strengths are in the
maths and sciences so like when it comes
to kind of making that stuff happen but
at the same time
if i went back in time even just a
couple years ago and said hey you're
going to make a couple chairs
and you're going to be so stoked about
them i would be like what the [ __ ] are
you talking about
i'm not a big you know furniture is cool
but like i'm not
going to be excited about chairs and
yeah it is funny where that takes you
you know
it kind of makes me think about change
and how you know
change is a scary thing um and i i think
it's not actually even that um
you know like for me the changes in my
life too uh
it's not that i'm so scared of where i'm
going it's that it's sort of a death of
the old
and again i'm not saying like this is
obviously a new hobby and i'm just sort
of i'm really extrapolating this idea
out into other spaces that
might be relatable for other people that
have things going on but but
you know you know this could lead to
your life being so different someday
and you know or just even
showing people how quickly you can you
know
learn more about yourself through
following these hobbies like have you
learned any
have you learned any lessons like is
there any sort of things that you can
pull from this experience and that
you're like wow that's actually a lesson
right there
yeah um gosh
uh i mean it's kind of reinforced some
lessons
in in a very palpable way like where
you know you know one of the big ones
actually is go with your gut
and that's such a lesson that
everybody's probably heard
and it's probably had something they can
reflect on where they did or didn't and
when are happy they did or wish they
did if they didn't uh but there's times
where you know i'm
if i have a dimension for example and i
think man this might not be quite right
i think i can make it work but i i don't
know you know and it might not be right
and then you keep going and then
way further down the project you realize
shoot you know i should have changed
that when i had the chance when it would
have been much easier and so just it
reinforces stuff like that
um patience is another big one and
that's a virtue when it comes to this
hobby like there are times when i
especially with these chairs it was my
first time making a project so it's
going to take me longer than it would if
i'd been doing it for years
obviously but man that testament just
seeing something through completion is
something i always want to do
but this like really was a test it was
just
i the last couple weeks i'm like oh my
god i don't want to finish you somebody
just
stain these just get this done like i
need to move on to the next thing
because it's like
been taking too much of my life right
now the joy is in the journey
yeah it is and it is i mean it really up
into that point
it really was like it's so fun because
it's kind of meditative
when you get in the shop it's you know
you have usually you have your
protection in because especially if
you're working with any of the power
tools they're allowed you have your dust
extraction like it's it's kind of
abusive on your ears and so i have
earplugs
and sometimes my like like i go to a
shooting range and stuff so i've got
like my
my muffs on top and um it went you kind
of helps you get in your own head it's
like
it's like a partial sensory deprivation
kind of thing
like a moving meditation yeah it is and
like
you're focused on that moment and then
your head can get away from you and you
just let it run wild and think about all
the thoughts that might be going on and
you just kind of escape from
reality and just get into your zone and
just enjoy it and i i
it is the joy is in the journey in that
way in a very big way
yeah you said trust your gut is there um
are there things going on right now
where you're like oh my god i know i
need to trust my gut on this one but
right now i'm like battling this like
i'm like i need to do this or i need to
do
that or i think this are there other
things that you're
that now that you've kind of been sort
of reinforced with that lesson of trust
your gut that you're like
ah damn it but i wasn't ready for that
one i don't know
um outside of the
shop and those i mean yeah nothing that
comes to mind that's such an awesome
question
no i can't think of it i can't think of
how that can apply to something outside
of that at the moment which is kind of
but yeah what about you
um um for me on things that i kind of
know
it's like i mean just things that
i need to move on from emotionally
mentally
um uh
trusting and knowing like really feeling
like yeah this is what i should be doing
right now with those travel that i love
and exploring and sort of like
being a bit of a nomad gypsy for a while
and just like
really like seeing the world
um like i haven't been single for 16
years so i'm like
i love traveling and so i'm trusting
sort of that
and trusting the flow i think sometimes
too it's a matter of
surrendering it's knowing what you want
but then
surrendering to the way that it ends up
going and thinking like
well if this goes away then it's meant
something else is meant to come in and
if
and if that uh and if this doesn't work
out something else will better
be better or if this is meant to be
it'll be easy and it'll just keep
flowing
and so yeah i think that sort of that
know it
that that in that sort of thought
is a matter of like learning how to flow
too
um because it's you have to get out of
the way of the mind
the mind has to get out of the way to
allow that stuff that you kind of know
to trust the gut right otherwise you're
back in your mind again and you're just
trying to use your you can only pull
from what you know when you're using the
mind but when you start using the body
and the intuition
and the knowing that is beyond the
rational
mind then it takes you to places that
you
haven't been before i think you said
that beautifully it's so true and it's
so hard for me to do that too it's like
i'm such a rational evidence right i go
off evidence-based
information i go off what makes the most
sense that's where i find myself
leaning towards whether it's you know
whatever it is and it's like if you can
back it up with
with evidence you know then great and so
i it's it's that it becomes hard for me
to go off
intuition and gut sometimes because i
want to think about well
why does this make sense why would it be
in that so it's
it's a fine line and sometimes it
becomes challenging but i think you're
totally right and but when
i'll tell you this i i don't think i've
ever
made a so anytime i've made a decision
based on my intuition and got off my gut
i don't think i've ever regretted it
yeah even if i was wrong in that
decision or it seemed wrong
and then maybe something else came out
of it then it ended up being right but
even if it doesn't seem right
it's like dude you can't feel bad about
going with your gut
like you you can't you know you just you
can't predict the future
and if it doesn't turn out the way you
thought or hoped it might you know you
can't feel bad about that and so
there's something to be said and just
kind of
letting go and not overthinking it and
just so hard
but it is it's it's harder it's easier
said than done it really i think it's a
bit and it's the you know for for
everyone we get in our head but i think
for men in general i think it can be a
little bit harder
um on top of it just because of ego and
sort of the patriarchal like
sort of dying you know dynamic we've
lived in for so long
um i think it can be a little harder for
men
so i my heart goes out oh thank you
i'm not judging at all your sympathy
yeah no no i don't i don't i mean you're
probably right
yeah that probably plays into it i
wouldn't be surprised at all i mean
there's a lot of preconceived
cultural um and uh
and just man versus women around the
world i mean or not first but you know
as compared to women yeah i mean that's
probably true i wouldn't i think that if
i'm get
if i'm feeling right i would imagine
though that you
you do use that sort of feeling and
intuition with your job because
animals can't speak to you literally
so you know you're having to use that
aspect of yourself
every day that you're that you're
working or shoot every day with your dog
you know you
you're using those intuitive emotional
skills to
to uh to do your work in a very real way
i mean
some of my favorite vets they'll remind
you that you know medicine
is an art it's not just a science it's
also an art so there's no black and
white there's no one way to do things
and sometimes you have a patient where
um
what would seem like the ideal thing to
do uh is actually going to end up being
detrimental
for example if i'm working with uh say a
high stress
uh prey animal species like even just
say a guinea pig
you know i'm like okay in one way this
guinea pig would really benefit from me
hospitalizing him getting iv fluids
right and doing all this intensive
treatment
then i think i know medically is in his
best interest
and then the other side of me is if i
have this animal here he's going to be
stressed out
he's not going to eat that's going to
throw off all his gut flora the stress
is going to affect his immune system and
everything's going to get messed up
because of that
even though i'm trying to do what's what
i what would make the most sense or what
should be the right thing so you have to
you constantly
having to evaluate what's best for that
patient and go off your gut and do
things that might not seem like it's the
best idea on paper
are based on the the research but for
that patient
it's really the most appropriate thing
to do so every every case can have some
element of that some are more
straightforward
than others not everyone is this like
battle but like there are some
complicated cases where
you know it's every time you get this
kind of thing it's not going to be the
same
you know it's always a different story
from one patient to the next and there's
so many there's so many variables and
factors and owner compliance and all
that kind of stuff that plays into it
uh you know how your how you're going to
decide to do what's best or what you
feel is best for this patient
i'm curious um because i feel
bad in this scenario for the animals but
what do you think about zoos i
okay so zoo the word zoo is such a big
broad word okay that means so many
things so when we're talking about
good quality zoos then our az
accredited which is the association of
zoos and aquariums which have
strict guidelines for how these animals
are cared for how these zoos uh give
back to conservation
their veterinary care their you know
their enrichment like all the things
that are important for these animals and
their wildlife counterparts
you know not just the tiger they have
here but also what are we doing for
tigers in sumatra what are we doing for
you know gorillas in the congo you know
um
those zoos are so incredibly important
for our wildlife
so incredibly important overall so good
zoos like the la zoo the san diego zoo
the henry doorly zoo
uh are so so good for animals and
wildlife i mean listen
there are some individuals in zoos that
might be not living their best life
and it's it's a heartbreaker and it's a
bummer and i'm not happy to see that by
any means
but you have to realize some of these
animals they're kind of an ambassador
for their species they're kind of taking
one for the team because
they are there to help give um
you know an experience to a child or or
an adult
to get eye contact with these animals
see what they're like and see you know
just just
have an appreciation for them at the at
the very basic level
okay and that's how we can connect most
people with wildlife most people aren't
lucky like you or i would we get to go
to peru and mexico and all over the
world and see animals and wildlife all
over the place that's where one of the
we're an exception
and so i've gotten to see all my
favorite animals and they're a lot of my
favorite animals in their native habitat
but
most people don't if they're ever really
going to lay their eyes on a gorilla
that's the only realistic way that
they're gonna do so
um and so but most these good zoos
they're they're giving these animals
good lives i'm not saying every animal
in the zoo
it just sucks to be them and they're not
happy like nature
is a [ __ ] i mean nature is not fun it's
not easy and it's
scary as hell it's not butterflies and
rainbows it's everyday find food
or be eaten find shelter deal with the
elements deal with tropical diseases
deal with infectious diseases and
parasites
deal with all the everything and it's
like every day is a struggle every day
is scary every day you might die
and a lot of these animals that are in
good quality zoos they're in a nice
habitat with good enrichment
uh they're social they have other
members of the same species they have
phenomenal vet care they have phenomenal
diet they get all their needs met
like they're living a good life i'm not
saying i want to take all the wild
animals and put them in captivity
but like it's not like it's so bad the
wild is not like just
it's not butterflies and rainbows you
know what i mean it's just not so
um that's i mean that's in a basic way
that's why it's important and if you
really understand what zoos do
for conservation i mean i've worked with
so many different zoo projects where
they're
going i mean when i did not long ago was
go to uganda and we're doing
a giraffe translocation we're taking
giraffe from a big national park and
putting them into another part of the
country where they've been locally
extinct there for 40 years
because i got poached out from bushmeat
by this
militant the lord's resistance army
which was like a super militant
guerrilla army that just went and raped
pills and killed
people over the country that didn't
agree with their values um
and so when we were doing that we had
people from the shine mountain zoo in
colorado and they're getting
skin samples dna samples uh they're
getting ecto parasites on these animals
and they're doing a lot of things
to learn more about these animals
compare them to what we know in
captivity
and learn how to better treat both
parties and bet and make
both both parties more healthy and then
of course they're part of that project
they're contributing to this happening
which was super important from a
conservation perspective
with the draft conservation foundation i
mean that zoos are behind a lot of this
work and the big zoos the good zoos
they do tremendous amounts uh towards
in the way of hands-on and direct and
even money-wise contributing to
the conservation of our wildlife around
the world what do you look
up to know if your zoo is what is the
certification
aza and that's that's let's answer your
question yeah if their association of
zoo and aquariums
uh accredited or certified yeah um then
it's
it's a good zoo you know you can pretty
much just yeah
black and white say that and there are
some other good zoos
that maybe don't have that uh
accreditation yet
all those big zoos have that but then i
said zoo is such a big word because
there's so many shitty little roadside
bs places trying to make some money that
have nothing to do with conservation
well what did you think about
tiger king then oh that's a whole other
i mean how did you i'm sure you've
talked about this a million times i hate
asking questions that i feel like you've
probably been asked but
oh i mean that was that was that was i'm
glad it gave people insight
onto the into the world of cub petting
and what it means to be tigers in
captivity because that was
horrible none of those places are doing
it right none of those places are doing
any real work towards conservation
i was trying to see what the difference
was between each of them and how
they like like oh carol baskin like
pretty sure she was doing the same thing
as what's the other guy named joe was
that what was his name
yeah joe exotic yeah i mean yeah they
kind of look like the same
totally sketchy and weird and she was in
it for different reasons to begin with
and then turn herself into some kind of
sanctuary so i mean
whatever and then you have that other
guy doing the cub petting and uh
yeah and then you know and then and then
i mean they're they're they're a bunch
of freaks and here's the thing with the
with the cup petting world okay uh
you're only legally allowed to use these
tigers to take for cub petting from like
i think it's like 8 to 16 or 12 to 16
weeks of age it's like this really short
window
of a life that can be into the early 20s
oh god
well through the teens and so you got a
widow of a month or two
um they don't have the means the
finances the space to care for every
animal they breed
and so they have these litters they sell
these animals
and they use this money as a in a like a
business
not using it for conservation or
anything they just sell these cubs to
other crappy zoos
that live in small chain link enclosures
in
or whatever uh sometimes they sell them
internationally and they go to places
like thailand
and they go to some other even sketchier
tiger exhibit because their laws are not
like ours
and many of those animals are euthanized
for the illegal black markets where
people want to get tiger bones and tiger
bladder and tiger teeth and tiger skin
and all this crap
for a profit i mean it's a really ugly
industry it's not doing
anything for the conservation of our
wild tigers
and most the tigers in those captive
situations are not living their best
life and it's just it just fuels this
ugly industry of something that should
not be the
you know that really shouldn't be it
shouldn't be that way that shouldn't be
how we appreciate tigers like yes
i you know i'd love for you know people
to get the interactions and i've been so
you know blessed to have with a lot of
wildlife around the world but petting
tiger cubs in that setting
and in that way with how that business
model works is not the right way to do
it and every time you support it
you know you're not doing any favors for
those individuals and you're definitely
not doing anything for tiger
conservation in a real way
yeah where can people go in your
experience
for those really authentic experiences
if someone's able to
have the means to travel um to to see
the most amount of wildlife
yeah i mean wildlife rescues are a
really cool way to get it close and
personal with wildlife and these are
places that
uh rescue and rehabilitate and ideally
release uh wildlife
uh that's native to wherever they are
and so i've been to you know
i was in one in peru i've been to one
you know all over south america i've
been to ones in central america
uh africa southeast asia australia and
these are places where
they take in their end their native
wildlife and then if they're injured or
orphaned
they try to rehabilitate them and get
them back in the wild
volunteering in a place like that you
can get great hands-on experience and
there's other places that are more
established like the
classic is like the elephant nature park
in chiang mai and thailand
and this is a place that takes in
elephants that you know
have gone through hell and back to be
used in the illegal logging
or the tourism industry and they get to
they live on this big open space and you
can volunteer even for a day to go you
know feed them
and spend some time with them and just
help out a little bit you get these
interactions with them
um some species it's hard to get up
close and personal with like tigers like
i mean i can't think of a place where
it's really
a great thing to go pet a tiger unless
you have some connection with the zoo
and they have some cubs that are going
to be staying in captivity and it's like
an okay thing but with that with some of
those species
a little bit tougher to try to pull that
off i love seeing the animals so
for me i i i i think i yeah
i mean i've been i've seen some animals
in different places maybe
um a few different countries i've been
in
and that seem like they have kind of
sanctuaries like that and maybe there's
like a cheetah or something like that
and
i'm obsessed i literally think maybe
this should be some parting words
i feel like i could pet a bobcat outside
the bobcat walk by i'd be like look
bobcat energetically
i think we could be friends is that a
bad idea
i admire your
that you would like to do that and that
you think you could do that and it's
pretty adorable and i think that's great
um listen uh okay so it
is for being serious like no i don't
encourage people to interact with
wildlife
and it's in the best interest of you and
the wildlife number one if you're in a
situation where you can get within arm's
reach of a bobcat i'd be worried about
you
okay so it probably means that animals
quarter and it can't get away because
any time you approach a wild bobcat
it really is wild it's going to want to
get away from you so if you get that
close
you're putting yourself in a dangerous
position i'm not saying a bobcat's going
to bite your neck and bleed you out and
kill you
but they can scratch you up they can
they can rough you up pretty good i mean
they're they're
a pretty capable and gnarly little
wildcat
um but you know you know when you when
you
do that and engage with wildlife like
that you affect their trust towards
people and most people they can't trust
um and then it makes them also a little
bit more dangerous because then they
think oh people are cool
i'm gonna walk into their house and eat
some of their food or into their yard
and that's where you get like
you know raccoons and bears and things
like that doing things that are not
actually in the best interest of the
people and the animals involved and so
that's
that's one thing um was it a bad idea
for because there's a lot of people that
have that feed them right they might
put food out for deer or feed food out
for
some like you know coyotes and stuff is
that a bad idea
i mean the only time i've ever
encouraged something like that has been
is when there's been like significant
natural disasters
that have just told their resources so
like for example when we had gnarly
fires in southern california
i would like on social media posts like
hey leave out some you know if you can
leave out some
some good hay and some water for the
deer or for some of the wildlife in your
area that'd be great like all their
resources are depleted their food and
everything has just been completely
destroyed and so you know there's
nothing wrong with doing a little bit of
that but for like normal
wildlife where they have means of you
know getting
what else they need they figured it out
you know more or less it's
yeah i mean you're just you're teaching
them to get too comfortable to people
you're teaching them potentially to
depend on people and then they don't
uh look out you know and you know
involve themselves ecologically where
they need to be
uh you know there's a whole ecological
system where every individual every
individual and every species plays a
role
and we don't want to take away from that
or affect that or you know
create a balance there and then just a
real quick thing where we're talking
about it if you don't mind
yeah when it comes to animals and
tourism
you know because we've been talking
about traveling and seeing animals i
just want to you know really
you're probably aware of this but i want
to just you know everybody you know
listening and watching
um be really hesitant you know anytime
you see somewhere where you can get a
monkey on your shoulder to take a
picture or a bird
or ride an elephant or have it paint a
picture for you or paid to have a
chimpanzee do a dance for you or any of
that kind of thing
like it's it's never good it's never in
the best interest of that individual
it's often not the best interest of that
species because those animals are
poached
and they're you know the babies are
stolen from their mothers in the wild
and the rest of the family's killed kind
of like horror stories like that that's
super common so
don't support that kind of tourism
because the
more you do the longer it's going to go
on and when people start realizing hey
this is bad we don't want to support it
the people that are doing that will stop
doing it they're going to do just what
they think can make money and if they
realize this isn't going to make us
money like they're just going to stop
doing it
this is an analogy for everything going
on in the world right now to be honest
so i'm so glad you said that because
it is through our participation in
things that they exist right so if
there's something out there that you
don't agree with and you don't want to
continue
you know let's say i don't know let's
say you think newspapers are [ __ ]
and the con you don't know if you should
trust the information stop buying them
stop looking at them if you think the tv
is telling you lies
stop watching the news because as soon
as you stop participating in the systems
or an elephant that could pay you a
picture or you know monkey on your
shoulder
you you dissolve you dissolve it because
this is a lovely little lesson
especially at this point in time and
the way everything's going in the world
is that we truly hold
power yeah the collective holds the
power to make the change
in any way that they want it's just that
it takes more than one of us
and so but yet you have to be the one
that makes the decision
so if we each individually decide to
make make
do things differently and participate in
things differently
then we create a different reality for
ourselves so i'm so glad you said that
because i think that's such a great
like way too
i mean i think that there's so many more
similarities with animals than we
recognize i mean what down to genetics
right
so oh yeah yeah no there's crossover in
parallel all over the place and i mean
just like you said that's what i say to
people
every time you click or like or pay for
what i mean you're voting
you're putting your vote out for there
and so you're saying that's what i want
even though you don't like it when you
watch it or you pay for it or you click
on it or
whatever yeah you cast your vote and so
if we don't vote for it
you know they're not going to do it
there you know like whatever it is if
it's not getting
you know people aren't voting for it
they're not getting the money they
thought they would or whatever it is
you know it's just it's going to
disappear but it's going to take
the majority to make that decision you
know that's so great
thank you for saying that and thank you
so much for sharing about the animals
and about your woodwork
yeah it was my pleasure i i've never
done that where i've like gone up like
oh let's go check out my woodshop but
i'm stoked on it i'm glad you took an
interest in it too and wanted to see it
and
make it i love that i'm really proud of
you for that that's that's so cool
um and vulnerable too you're like um i
like woodworking here we go
yep pretty much super stellar i mean but
you should because look at what you've
done
oh and i can't wait for my for my
cutting board so cutting board and
driving lessons
we've got so much to do and snakes
that's right i'm such a snake person
snakes we're both going to benefit from
but i'll get you bored you you get me
behind the wheel
done deal thank you
yeah thank you thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today i hope you enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button